-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Jazz cymbals play ]
What is that?
Oh.
Hi.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, who --
Oh, I'm sorry, who --
Who -- Who are --
Who are you?
♪ Well, I'm a spooky spider ♪
♪ I'm a Halloween fright ♪
♪ With some safety tips
this Halloween night ♪
♪ When you go trick-or-treating,
go with a group ♪
♪ Take care not to trip
over pumpkins on stoops ♪
♪ Don't use silly strings ♪
♪ Never throw eggs ♪
♪ Take it from me
because I've got eight legs ♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy Halloween.
-I'm so sorry.
What's happening?
Right, spooky spider,
it's nowhere near Halloween.
You're either six months early
or five months late.
[ Laughter ]
-I see.
[ Jazz cymbals play ]
Well, in that case...
♪ I'm a Valentine's spider ♪
♪ A spooky fright ♪
♪ With some dating tips
this Valentine night ♪
♪ Gaslighting is real ♪
♪ Which is why
you need boundaries ♪
-Stop, wait! Stop, stop!
I'm gonna stop you right there.
I'm gonna stop you.
Sorry, uh, uh, spooky spider.
Valentine's Day was last month.
-For real?
-Yeah, for real.
Uh, how -- how long
did it take you
to make your way
up to the East Coast?
Are you one of those
joro spiders?
-Well, let's -- let's see.
I remember a strong breeze
picked me up right after
I went to see
"Jumanji: The Next Level."
-Okay.
That's 2019.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
And Biden's got his work
cut out for him
if he wants to win
the presidency next year.
-It is March 2022.
-Say what?
Hold on a minute.
Let me check my --
Let me check
my T-Mobile Sidekick here.
-Wait.
You have a T-Mobile Sidekick?
-Oh, jealous?
This baby is sweet.
SMS text messaging,
full QWERTY keyboard,
1G and 3 bars.
[ Chuckles ]
-Spooky spider, I think
it's time for you to go.
-Very well. I'm off to see
the new Batman movie.
-Oh, yeah? Robert Pattinson
is fantastic as Batman.
-The guy in "Twilight"?
No, I'm talking about Affleck.
You know, Batman.
-All right.
Spooky spider, everyone.
Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."